interesting time slot when you were in
Woodstock you were on in the kind of the
middle of the night weren't you
well we were promised a primetime on a
Saturday night like 9 o'clock yeah what
they didn't tell me is you're gonna
follow the Grateful Dead the best thing
I can say about all of that because they
finally have admitted what well things
went sorely wrong after they hit the
stage everybody was running late of
course hippies had been putting on this
thing and I think the Grateful Dead
those damn hippies Hey
anyway back then we were all hippies
come on but the dad didn't go on till
about midnight but what they didn't tell
us until the nineties was they had all
taken LSD just as they went onstage
right and so about the middle of their
set it went dead silent I think I don't
really know what happened because I
wasn't watching the stage I was only
hearing anyway it was quiet for about an
hour and then he started playing again
and so
hey I think somebody figured out how to
plug in right but anyhow so they were
probably playing for an hour but not
making any noise something like that
they had a great time and we had to
follow that and so it was literally 2:30
in the morning
I come running out because this was a
big chance sure there's a half a million
people there I come running out and I
look down there and I see a bunch of
people look a lot like me he except
they're naked yeah yeah and they're
asleep yeah they were all kind of piled
together it looked like one of those
pictures of the souls coming up out of
hell yeah Dante's Inferno or is it yeah
but they're all you know asleep so we
started rocking out yeah trying to eat
in the middle of the night in the middle
of nowhere trying to get things going
here finally I went up to the mic I've
kind of apologetically yeah we'd played
probably five rockers and I said well I
hope you're enjoying some of this we're
having a great time up here we just want
you to like us you know we're rockin out
hey out there about a quarter mile some
guys flicking his lighter he says don't
worry about it John we're with ya
so in front of a half-a-million people
for the rest of my big Woodstock concert
yeah I played for that guy right right
now there's probably a half a million of
ya